dieses urteil wird weltweit beachtung
finden denn es ist auch eine kampfansage
an alle kriegsverbrecher die botschaft
ist ganz klar egal wo auf der welt die
unter taucht ihr könnt für eure taten
bestraft werden das waren die wahren
worte der zdf rechts reporterin sara
tacke vergangene woche live vom
oberlandesgericht koblenz und dieses
urteil das einen warnschuss an alle
kriegsverbrecher und folterer sendet
beschäftigt uns auch heute hier in folge
193 das faz einspruch podcast der
wöchentlichen podcast faz für recht
justiz und politik mein name ist corinna
budras ich bin berlin korrespondent in
der faz und mit dabei ist außerdem
verlor ins freie journalistin und
anwältin aus köln 9 genau dieser podcast
geht übrigens inzwischen fast
ausschließlich auf höherer anregungen
zurück das wollte ich bei dieser
gelegenheit mal sagen ja inzwischen
bekommen wir so viele hinweise dass wir
locker zwei stunden füllen könnten und
dafür herzlichen dank ja gerne
weitermachen und deshalb hier vielleicht
noch mal die e mail unter der man uns
erreichen kann das nämlich ganz einfach
einspruch podcast
faz.de was wären wir ohne sie ohne euch
dann starten wir also jetzt mit dem
themen wir gehen also mit einem
schwerpunkt zum besagten prozess das
oberlandesgericht koblenz hat den
syrischen geheimdienst mitarbeiter arno
r zu lebenslanger haft verurteilt und
zwar wegen eines verbrechens gegen die
menschlichkeit mord folter
schwerwiegender freiheitsberaubung
geiselnahme vergewaltigung und sexueller
nötigung es war wirklich ein gruseliger
fall den ich mit dem
menschenrechtsanwalt fritz streif
besprechen möchte er hat diesen zwei
jahre dauernden prozess intensiv mit
einem podcast begleitet für den ich hier
auch gleich noch mal eine höhere
empfehlung aussprechen müsst möchte er
hat nämlich brunch
251 also bench to 50 warum dazu kommen
wir gleich und so und dann wird es ein
bisschen nüchterner ab da wird es auch
etwas profaner trotzdem aber total
wichtig in der vergangenen woche quasi
während wir die letzte folge
aufgezeichnet haben hat der bgh zu
gewerbemieten im lockdown entschieden
und in der kategorie was kommt war
natürlich anfang der woche ein
ziemlicher knaller dass das jetzt schon
kam der § 209 10 a strafgesetzbuch wird
abgeschafft also das werbeverbot für
schwangerschafts abbrüche also und dann
gibt es noch einige hörer mails und ein
paar nachträge und da wollen wir eine
besondere aufmerksamkeit auf die
änderungen beim genesenen status und
beim impfstatus lenken die werden seit
einigen tagen heftig diskutiert vor
allen dingen auf twitter und dann hast
du uns noch ein gerechtes urteil
mitgebracht janne ein relativ schönes
gerechtes urteil wenn auch
möglicherweise mit sehr ernstem
hintergrund
wunderbar also dann liegen wir doch mal
los
[Musik]
wir beginnen den podcast diesmal gleich
mit unserem schwerpunkt thema denn das
hat es in sich sie haben es gleich zu
anfang des podcast gehört wie schauen
auf ein verfahren das in der ganzen welt
große aufmerksamkeit erfahren hat und
ich freue mich jemand zu sprechen der
von anfang an sehr intensiv das ganze
verfahren verfolgt hat nicht nur
verfolgt sondern man kann sagen
begleitet hat herzlich willkommen fritz
streif hallo schön schön zu sein herr
streif ich möchte sie erst einmal für
unsere hörerinnen und hörer vorstellen
damit die wissen was sie erwartet also
sie können ja mit einer sehr
ungewöhnlichen kombination aufwarten sie
sind praktizierende anwalt also anwalt
in die niederlande dann übrigens
zugelassen und gleichzeitig podcaster da
kommen wir auch gleich darauf zu
sprechen sie haben in utrecht studiert
nicht mehr jura sondern aus einem jura-
und philosophie und mathematik das
stimmt so offen ja also mathematik war
ein kurzer
er könnte es war ein liberal arts
studium also da konnte man alles so ein
bisschen bunt durcheinander griff so
dann haben sie in den niederlanden
zunächst bei der wirtschaftskanzlei
gearbeitet bevor sie zur open society
justice initiative in nach new york
gegangen sind und dann auch dafür diese
organisation in london gearbeitet haben
und jetzt sind sie in paris und da
berater in menschenrechtsfragen so und
dann genommen beginnen wir doch jetzt
einfach mal ganz trivial worum ging es
eigentlich in dem verfahren vor dem
oberlandesgericht koblenz
also sie haben es das schon jetzt schon
angedeutet ist tatsächlich ein
spezielles verfahren es wurde ja auch
groß der berichterstattung erwähnt weil
es eben weltweit das erste
strafverfahren ist gegen syrische
ehemalige in diesem fall syrische
geheimdienst mitarbeiter regime
mitarbeiter und zwei angeklagte etwas
weniger lang führungsschwächen wichtiger
der etat der schon im februar letzten
jahres das urteil bekommen hat zu
viereinhalb jahren verurteilt wurde und
in der hauptangeklagte an war er der
jetzt gerade verurteilt wurde und es
ging dabei um deren rolle in einer
abteilung des allgemeinen geheimdienstes
in syrien geheimdienste werden schon
geraume zeit eingesetzt um dissidenz im
eigenen land zu unterdrücken und seit
2011 das hat jetzt die vorsitzende
richterin in koblenz auch noch einmal
klar gemacht in der urteilsverkündung
wirklich nicht nur eben um informationen
zu erpressen
von von den gefangenen sondern
tatsächlich diese aufständigen das sind
ihre worte zu vernichten also für
physische vernichtung des aufstandes und
die individuellen anklagepunkte sagen
eigentlich schon alles im ersten falle
des desserts ja wie schon gesagt etwas
weniger material sagen wir mal so es war
in seiner rolle als weniger eigentlich
ein sammler als er war in einen stoß
truppe die die demonstranten
eingesammelt hat in minibussen dann zu
der abteilung gebracht hat und da
eigentlich der diesen leuten im
schicksal überlassen hat das dann
wiederum
eben von dem hauptangeklagten an war er
in einer höheren position nämlich der
ist leiter der ermittlungsabteilung und
des gefängnisses laut des laut des
urteils dafür verantwortlich war als
mittäter wie diese menschen dann dort
behandelt wurden also wir haben es hier
mit jemandem zu tun der für den
geheimdienst gearbeitet hat für den
syrischen geheimdienst gearbeitet hat
und der gleichzeitig auch zuständig war
für ein gefängnis in damaskus
genau in damaskus und es ist ja es ist
relativ unglaublich eigentlich also
dieses gefängnis mitten in der mascus
gelegen nach einer großen hauptstraße
die ins zentrum führt der der albstraße
deswegen auch der der name der oft
genannt wurde der alltag hat die prozess
und eben das alternativ gefängnis in
einem ehemaligen wohn
apartmentkomplex fünf stücke etwa
gegenüber eines parks gelegen das
gefängnis wein im kellergeschoss
gegenüber auf der straße gab es eine
eine apotheke 50/100 meter die straße
runter war eine klinik des des roten
halbmond ist also es war wirklich mitten
in der stadt oder ist man muss immer
wieder sagen ist mir in der stadt ist
das geht ja auch weiter jetzt leider
heutzutage und in diesem gefängnis sind
fürchterliche 10 passiert sind
fürchterlich gräueltaten passiert an den
gefangenen die wurden gefoltert sie
wurden unter druck gesetzt ihn wurde
buchstäblich das leben zur hölle gemacht
und jetzt hatten wir zum ersten mal die
situation dass ich tatsächlich zwei
menschen darunter eben vor allen dingen
der gefängnisleiter anouar vor gericht
verantworten mussten vor überhaupt es
war das erste verfahren weltweit
genau man muss ja vielleicht noch dazu
sagen im fall gegen den eta ging es um
insgesamt im endeffekt etwa 35 fälle von
folter in dem fall dass das album
4000 folter fälle die ihm vorgeworfen
wurden und mehr als 50 tötung zu dieser
morde die im vorgeworfen wurden dazu
kann dann auch sexualisierte gewalt und
vergewaltigungen
und noch eine reihe anderer
anklagepunkte die zum teil eben auch als
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
angeklagt und jetzt auch verurteilt
genau das ist ja in der tat ein begriff
aus dem völkerrecht da kommen wir gleich
auch noch mal dazu vielleicht zunächst
einmal noch zu den opfern wir waren die
leute die da so drangsaliert wurden an
also der fall konzentriert sich jetzt
nicht auf die die letzten jahre in
syrien sondern wirklich auf den anfang
den beginn der verbrecherischen antwort
des assad-regimes auf den aufstand 2011
also arabischer frühling kommt an in
syrien die leute gehen auf die straße
und in der urteilsverkündung hat die
vorsitzende richterin das noch mal sehr
ausführlich auch noch mal erzählt und
dargelegt und teil des des urteils
gemacht dass eben dann die entscheidung
getroffen wurde vom assad-regime und dem
inneren zirkel dem inneren machtzirkel
um eben mit gewalt diesen aufstand
nieder zuzudrücken und eben die
aufständischen die dann einkassiert
wurden und in solchen gefängnissen wie
der abteilung 251 gefangen wurden
tatsächlich auch physisch zu vernichten
darum ging es ist wann präsidenten ist
an demonstranten es waren leute die eben
im kontext des arabischen frühlings ist
sich nicht länger gefallen lassen haben
was um sie herum geschieht und
veränderung eingefordert haben
und dann war ja das interessante dass
anna also der mann der hier er ist
angeklagt und in der vergangene woche
auch verurteilt wurde ja eigentlich mit
dem system abgeschlossen hatte eine den
er war als flüchtling nach deutschland
gekommen so kam die ganze sache
überhaupt für die deutsche gerichte denn
man muss ja auch sagen das wird ja auch
alles ein bisschen bitter wir haben sehr
hier eigentlich mit einem rein syrischen
sachverhalt zu tun in die opfer sind
syrer der angeklagte ist syrer das ganze
spielte ihm in damaskus und trotzdem
haben die deutschen gerichte hier etwas
zu sagen vielleicht erklären sie uns
noch mal erstens wieso das überhaupt
aufflog und warum die deutschen gerichte
zuständig sind
ja die geschichte wahr ist ist
tatsächlich
interessant und und war natürlich auch
hauptbestandteil der verhandlungen jetzt
in koblenz was richtig ist also was
tatsächlich festgestellt wurde ist das
relativ schnell das hat auch niemand
bestritten ist natürlich dass der dass
der januar er desertiert ist ende 2012
und als flüchtling nach deutschland
gekommen ist sogar unter einem mit hilfe
eines visums für besonders
schutzbedürftige syrer sich bestimmten
aktivitäten der organisierten opposition
auch angeschlossen hatte was nicht
wirklich vom vom gericht festgestellt
wurde aber auch nicht notwendig
verhandelt werden muss sind die genauen
umstände seiner flucht aus syrien und
natürlich auch seine motivation also es
ist nicht so dass man sagen kann dieser
tür ist dieser tür
man hat es gibt zweifel bei seiner
motivation es könnten auch wirklich das
wurde angedeutet vom gericht einfach
optimistisch gewesen sein dass dieser
mann gesehen hat dass das regime
möglicherweise bald fällt die rebellen
standen vor den toren von damaskus ende
2012 und dass er einfach seine seine
chance an der anderswo gesehen hat und
deswegen desertiert ist ja das ist auch
eine möglichkeit andere der satire wie
zum beispiel der cesar der ehemalige
militär fotograf wird das sind leute die
sich auch vom regime abgewandt haben die
dann aber die entscheidung getroffen
haben sich wirklich 100 abzuwenden und
mitzuhelfen die verbrechen aufzudecken
diese entscheidung hat der anderen nicht
getroffen er hat mehr oder weniger sich
eigentlich gefunden in der mitte ist
auch nie mehr wirklich herausgekommen
bis zum ende des prozesses er hat zwar
wieder betont ist er als sich abgewandt
hat vom regime aber hat nie wirklich
hundertprozentig kooperiert und geholfen
auch in diesem verfahren spezifisch die
verbrechen aufzudecken also es ist so so
einfach ist es nicht also eine sehr
komplexe persönlichkeit genau sie haben
ihm den militär fotografen caesar
genannte der hier auch eine besondere
rolle spielt weil der nämlich tausende
von fotos gemacht hat von den opfern
dokumentiert hat was da passiert ist
auch die gräueltaten tatsächlich
sichtbar gemacht haben auf seinen fotos
gut auch wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe ein großteil der der untersuchung
und der anklage ist das so richtig ja
das kann man so sagen genau er hat eben
mit mit den fotos die er wirklich unter
absoluter lebensgefahr zusammen mit
einem gehilfen namens sami außer landes
geschaffen hat und die dann eben den
behörden übergeben hat hier hat er dazu
beigetragen dass diese dinge überhaupt
und die struktureller art dieser
verbrechen also die qualifikation dass
das verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
sind da hat er maßgeblich zu beigetragen
und das hat eben an war er zum beispiel
nicht getan sagt dass er versprochen
hatte damals alle möglichen dokumente
und alle möglichen informationen mit
raus zu nehmen und zu übergeben deshalb
wenn man das so nachlesen kann nicht
stattgefunden also wie gesagt es ist ein
bisschen eine schwierige eine schwierige
nummer aber tatsache ist er kam in
deutschland an als flüchtling wurde als
eben von den vom bundesamt für migration
und asyl wurde wurde er als solches ja
in deutschland dann auch willkommen
geheißen
hatte eigentlich asylstatus bekommen
bevor sich an vermittlung beginne ja ja
in seinem fall soweit wir das
recherchiert haben auf grundlage seiner
seines status hatte er den und war dann
aber wie viele tausende hunderttausende
andere syhre in deutschland auch in
einem flüchtlingszentrum untergebracht
in marienfelde in berlin
und ja und es gab verschiedene stränge
eigentlich die dazu geführt haben dass
er dann im endeffekt von einer anderen
behörde das muss man immer wieder sagen
das ist da gibt's natürlich auch eine
scheidung der macht der macht zwischen
dem bundesamt für migration und asyl und
dem
justizminister im ministerium
verschiedene stränge die dazu geführt
haben dass er dann untersucht wurde und
dann verhaftet und angeklagt wurde also
es wurde viel darüber berichtet dass er
wohl erkannt wurde von anderen führen
dass er erkannt wurde auch von von
aktiven syrien in diesem raum für
gerechtigkeit für syrien vom syrischen
menschenrechtsanwalt an boni das ist
eine sache eine andere sache war dass er
wohl aus angst dass er verfolgt wurde
von dem syrischen geheimdienst im
ausland also in deutschland und dass die
ihn wohl so sagte er vor gericht
verfolgten und umbringen wollten ihn
kidnappen und bringen wollten weil er
desertiert war aus dieser angst heraus
sagt er hätte er sich freiwillig beim
lka in berlin gemeldet und dort wohl
ziemlich freimütig seine geschichte
erzählt das wurde erst mal so
protokolliert und wurde dann erst mal
nichts mit unternommen als er dann aber
in einer anderen sache als zeuge beim
lka in stuttgart ausgesagt hat und dann
noch mal nachgefragt wurde was war denn
eigentlich ihre eigene rolle und er
wieder relativ freimütig davon erzählt
hat dass er diese rolle innehatte da
wurden dann langsam die die die behörden
aufmerksamen haben dann informationen
miteinander ausgetauscht und dann kam es
zu der anklage sie haben jetzt eben die
rolle noch mal erwähnt das sollten wir
präzisieren seine rolle als
gefängnisleiter war ja nicht dass er
selber die folter durchgeführt hat aber
man geht davon aus dass er sehr sehr
genau wusste was da passiert dass er die
schreie gehört hat dass er als
gefängnisleiter natürlich vielleicht die
noch nicht mal selbst angeordnet aber es
zumindest auch nicht verhindert hat ist
das so hinreichend beschrieben genau so
ist es und das hat die vorsitzende
richterin in der urteilsbegründung auch
noch mal wiederholt also die die es ist
eine mittäterschaft die festgestellt
wurde da ist natürlich keine direkte
täterschaft notwendig zu beweisen 4000
fälle von folter da hat die richterin
sehr präzise noch mal erklärt wie sie
auf diese zahl gekommen sind dass die
stattgefunden haben aufgrund der beweise
die die vorgetragen wurden vor gericht
und dass er eben genau in der position
war als leiter sowohl der
ermittlungsabteilung als auch das
gefängnis ist dies zumindest zu
verhindern hätte er es gewollt und dass
es wenigstens billig in kauf genommen
hat und das reicht schon für die
verurteilung als mittäter aber selbst
hand angelegt dafür gab es jedenfalls
keine beweise so und dann haben wir eben
einfach die situation dass die
bundespolizei anfängt zu ermitteln zu
sagen haben skurrile typen der zweite
als flüchtling anerkannt ist auf der
anderen seite aber wirklich auch
offensichtlich dreck am stecken hat und
dann haben wir eben die besonderheit
dass normalerweise weise könnte man ja
sagen ist er deutschland vielleicht
nicht als erste zuständig ab sondern man
würde niemals in den vergangenen jahren
auch immer wieder in unterschiedlichen
konstellationen gesehen hat den
internationalen strafgerichtshof in den
haag da in der pflicht sehen die kam gar
nicht zum zuge
dass also das ist ja so ein bisschen die
tragik des ganzen syrien dossiers dass
das nach in den ganzen jahren der
verbrechen die begangen wurde neben es
ist nie dazu gekommen ist dass wie man
es erwarten würde es zu einem
internationalen strafverfahren in den
haag beim internationalen strafen kommen
ist oder ein spezielles syrien tunnel
errichtet wurde wie zum beispiel nach
den beispielen von
jugoslawien vom ehemaligen jugoslawien
und ruanda oder anderen internationalen
uno-tribunal beides mehr oder weniger
weil einfach politisch international
politisch blockiert wurde vor allem von
russland und china im sicherheitsrat in
new york man muss aber auch noch mal
vielleicht ein schritt zurück nehmen und
sagen die idealvorstellung einer
gerechtigkeit für die die schrecklichen
verbrechen die in syrien passiert sind
und weiterhin passieren ist natürlich
gerechtigkeit dort selbst also das wäre
die theorien in der tat ja dass das
hören wir auch immer wieder von unseren
syrischen kollegen das ist natürlich der
anfang der tragik dass das absolut
unmöglich ist das faire und ja
ganzheitliche prozesse in syrien selbst
stattfinden würden oder oder in der
region in nachbarstaaten das ist leider
tatsächlich weiterhin unmöglich deswegen
ist diese internationale schiene dann
das die zweitbeste möglichkeit wenn man
es so nennen möchte die allerdings
blockiert ist international und dann
kommt eben die sogenannte drittbeste
möglichkeit ins bild und das sind
nationale strafprozesse die jetzt der in
koblenz und und andere über die wir
vielleicht gleich noch sprechen könnte
jetzt gerade beginnen oder oder
demnächst beginnen werden und das alles
auf basis das weltrechtsprinzip
vielleicht erklären sie erst mal ganz
kurz wir haben auch viele nicht juristen
unter unserer hörer was verbirgt sich
dahinter
das weltrechtsprinzip ein anfang
ursprünglich beim internationalen
strafwurf wiederum in den haag der seit
anfang des jahrhunderts existierte und
damals eben ins leben gerufen wurde und
eigentlich alle mitgliedsstaaten die
sich da angeschlossen haben das war teil
verhandlungen die zu der gründung des
straff geführt haben dass die
mitgliedsstaaten selbst eben auch die
internationalen verbrechen jede strafe
in den haag verfolgen kann auch selbst
kriminalisiert um eben möglicherweise
selbst prozess zu führen und den den
strafwurf in den haag nicht zu
überlasten das ist also die ethik und
idee damals so und deutschland wie eben
auch alle anderen mitgliedstaaten es
wurde diesen in den staaten eine gewisse
freiheit eingeräumt wie sieht es in den
eigenen gesetzen übernehmen wollten und
deutschland das eben im
völkerstrafgesetzbuch damals sehr direkt
und in einer relativ puren version
eigentlich übernommen das heißt im
vergleich zu anderen europäischen
nachbarstaaten ist es in deutschland
vielleicht am einfachsten für die
behörden wirklich diese fälle anzuklagen
und dann auch vor gericht zu bringen die
sie haben schon gesagt anfangs die
begangenen taten müssen keinen bezug zu
deutschland haben es mussten nicht mal
der täter oder das opfer auch nur ein
hauch von bezug zu deutschland haben
formell und trotzdem können diese diese
verfahren in deutschland geführt werden
und das ist auch im internationalen
vergleich relativ speziell und meiner
sicht extrem gut eine sache die ich dazu
noch sagen möchte ist das finde ich auch
wichtig er in bezug auf die legitimation
eines solchen verfahrens das ist ja
immer so ein bisschen die frage was
macht denn eigentlich deutschland hier
warum werdender ressourcen eingesetzt
zeit und was nimmt sich deutschland
eigentlich heraus die diese syrische
sache sozusagen zu behandeln und auch
abzuurteilen und da spielt glaube ich
vielleicht noch mal eine große rolle und
ist deswegen auch deutschland da aktiv
geworden und jetzt auch finde ich gut
das ist dass das das land ist dass
diesen ersten prozess im endeffekt
relativ gut über die bühne gebracht hat
wir können gleich noch sprechen über die
über die lessons learned aber das ist
einfach extrem viele syrische
mitbewohner in unserer land gibt ja bis
zu 800.000 syrer sind in deutschland und
da sich darunter eben auch viele opfer
die sich einfach weil sie sich an
niemand anderes haben wenden können an
die deutschen behörden gewandt haben
gesagt haben wir sind hier wir möchten
gerechtigkeit das deutsche gesetz ist
dafür gemacht und in dem sinne ist es
schon finde ich was die legitimation des
verfahrens angeht gut das ist in
deutschland passiert ist und in dem
sinne als drittbeste lösung auch zu
befürworten also weltrechtsprinzip gibt
es in deutschland aber auch noch nicht
so lange also umgesetzt ist glaube ich
erst rund vor 20 jahren und seitdem
sehen wir auch erst die tendenz dass
auch große prozesse sind ja eben meist
große prozesse sehr komplexe prozesse
sehr komplizierte verfahren auch so
schon schwierig sind sachverhalt
überhaupt aufzuklären seitdem sehen wir
so tröpfchenweise eigentlich immer mehr
dieser verfahren so und nun an war
musste sich also stellen weil auch
langes verfahren über 100
verhandlungstage mehrere jahre zog sich
das und das gericht hat nun vergangene
woche vergangenen donnerstag das urteil
gesprochen und kam tatsächlich zu einer
verurteilung lebenslange haft für
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit aber
das sollte man vielleicht an dieser
stelle nochmal sagen in
sicherungsverwahrung muss er nicht das
stand ja auch zur debatte ob er
vielleicht womöglich weit über die
üblichen jahre hinaus noch hinter
verschlossene türen kommt weil er eine
gefahr für die gesellschaft sieht da so
weit ist das gericht aber nicht gegangen
genau also verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit ist ein tatbestand des
weltrechtsprinzip dazu das muss man
vielleicht mal kurz sagen zählen auch
völkermord und kriegsverbrechen in dem
rahmen ist es ist es eben nach koblenz
gekommen auf grundlage des vetorechts
prinzip ist und jetzt zum urteil
ich glaube sie haben das absolut
treffend zusammengefasst ich glaube das
ist auch fair also die meisten
anklagepunkte hat das gericht als wiesn
festgestellt ein paar von denen morgen
konnten nicht nachgewiesen werden aber
es ging immer glaube ich immer noch wenn
ich richtig herum 27 morde und eben wie
gesagt 4000 fälle von folter dazu eben
sexualisierte gewalt ein fall von
vergewaltigung also das als verbrechen
gegen die menschlichkeit und da eben
verbrechen gegen menschlichkeit mord
also da ist aber lebenslänglich nicht
keine andere option als leben
lebenslänglich sie sagen es aber schon
ist wurde nicht entschieden dass die
besondere schwere der schuld fest und
würdiger gehirn und ging natürlich um
die besondere schwere der schuld und
nicht an diesen zwar genau die besondere
schwere der schuld da haben wir unter
juristen viel diskutiert ob das gericht
diese feststellen würde und das war für
mich eigentlich als ich dann nach
koblenz gefahren letzte woche die
einzige frage die sich mir gestellt hat
und war relativ schnell beantwortet dass
es eben nicht festgestellt wurde das
hätte bedeutet dass andere eben nicht
nach 15 jahren in wien wie normalerweise
üblich über lebenslangen haftstrafen
eine freilassung auf bewährung
beantragen kann sondern eben mindestens
20 jahre hätte warten müssen das ist
aber nicht festgestellt und was ich
schon sagte ich finde dass im endeffekt
fair es ist kein fall gewesen der
absolut
eindeutig in regime eine ehemalige
mitarbeiter der weiterhin feuer und
flamme für das regime ist und ein großes
theater politisches theater gemacht hat
vom prozess und alles abgestritten hat
das hat es ja auch schon gegeben in der
internationalen rechtsgeschichte nein er
hat will das habe ich schon gesprochen
er hat sich jedenfalls formell abgewandt
vom regime und hat teilweise auch in
seiner einlassung anfangs im prozess
bestimmte dinge eingeräumt leider hat er
nicht komplett kooperiert und
mitgearbeitet
in anführungsstrichen an seiner eigenen
verurteilung das hätte ihm vielleicht
noch mehr geholfen aber es wurde ihm
zugute gehalten dass er eben nicht
hundertprozentige regime assad folglich
ist sondern eben na ja wir haben
gesprochen da etwas anders gesehen
werden er kann oder muss und deswegen
die besondere schwere der schuld eben
nicht festgestellt werden sagen sie nun
würde ich ganz gerne auf ihr eigenes
projekt zu sprechen kommen denn sie
haben dieses verfahren ja begleitet ich
habe es anfangs schon gesagt mit einem
eigens dafür
hergestellten podcast sind sich mensch
zu 150
das bezieht sich darauf dass das die
abteilung warne
251 in der das alles stattfand
vielleicht berichten sie uns mal ein
bisschen von ihrem projekt so etwas war
im podcast der auf englisch erschienen
ist und syrisch und das den ganzen ganze
verfahren begleitet hat netz endlich
genau genau also die idee für den
podcast kam eigentlich relativ spontan
podcast an sich bin ich schon lange bin
ich lange hörer und und fan und
konsumiere seit mehr als zehn jahren
selbst aber hat eben auch als ich in new
york gewohnt habe damals ich wartete
noch auf meine arbeitserlaubnis habe ich
in meinem kurs gemacht bei der new york
university im podcasting und radio
reporting- und endlich einfach ist
einfach spannend und interessant fand
und ein bisschen gelernt wie man an so
einem projekt herangeht und auch die
technischen fragen so ein bisschen
gelernt und hab ich seitdem du bist ein
bisschen gewartet auf thema um mal
selbst ein podcast zu machen und dann
kam eben dieser prozess der von
vornherein natürlich war das erste mal
war wie schon besprochen vorhin eben
historisch irgendwie sein würde das war
klar und und deswegen dachte ich mensch
vielleicht ist podcasting ja ganz
interessant das medium um einen prozess
zu verfolgen und zu begleiten und von
vorneherein war die idee es zu machen
eben nicht aus der distanzierten sicht
eines deutschen
auf englisch und sondern eben mit syrien
zusammen begonnen hat das ganze mit
einem syrische journalisten und ist dann
später gewachsen noch mit noch mit
mehreren syrischen kollegen
zusammengearbeitet sondern eben auch auf
arabisch und nicht nur weil es bezüglich
irgendwie in syrischer prozess ist der 2
in deutschland stattfindet sind nicht
nur weil es sich um syrien weil sie von
syrien handelt sondern weil eben auch
schon absehbar war dass es schwierig
werden würde für syrer in der ganzen
welt sich zu informieren zu diesem
prozess und das hat das hat sich dann
auch später einfach leider bewahrheitet
und bis zum ende durchgezogen das ist
eine sehr restriktive auslegung gibt der
deutschen gerichte was den zugang zum
gericht selbst das hat auch mit kurve zu
tun muss man dem gerichts gut erhalten
zum gerichts selbst also ist eine
verhandlung aber eben auch zu den
übersetzungen gibt zwar wirklich finde
ich weiterhin erstaunlich ist wurde im
prozess selbst für die teilnehmenden
nebenkläger und staatsanwaltschaft und
die verteidigung wurde natürlich
simultan übersetzt es gab zwei
simultanübersetzer im raum im saal aber
diese übersetzungen die
durften eben nicht an die öffentliche
tribüne weiter gegeben werden obwohl sie
simultan stattgefunden hat das ist
weiterhin unbegreiflich finde ich wurde
auch
vertreter der nebenklage öfters auch
offiziell beim gericht beantragt das
bitteschön zugänglich zu machen das hat
nicht stattgefunden also und dann ist es
eben im internationalen vergleich auch
so es gibt keinerlei
abschriften der verhandlungstage das ist
im internationalen vergleich anders in
der tat so genanntes viele defizite die
sich zieren so aufsehen
vollmann deutlich werden was da
eigentlich fragt und wie schwer das auch
den menschen gemacht werden die
interesse daran haben
das ganze zu verfolgen so und sie haben
dann eben einfach kurzerhand einen
podcast draufgemacht der in zwei
sprachen erschien um den syrern auch
quasi die möglichkeit zu geben sich
daran zu beteiligen bzw das zu verfolgen
wie waren die reaktionen insbesondere
aus diesem teil der welt oder vielleicht
auch von schülern aus deutschland
ja also noch mal kurz ist wurden sogar
auch audioaufnahmen beantragt ist wurde
auch abgelehnt von gerichten also und
das ist die brücke zu unserem projekt
audio zugänglich aus der ganzen welt
relativ einfach mit dem smartphone und
das war die idee des ganzen dass das
eben nicht nur in deutschland oder wo
auch immer zugang haben können es zu
informationen als riesen gericht sondern
eben von wo auch immer sie kann das auch
nachverfolgen ebenso eine datenanalyse
plattform wo wir sehen wo gehört wird
und von wem und das ist ja da kann man
relativ deutlich sehen dass es in den
zentren der syrischen diaspora im
ausland die sagen aber die hotspots gibt
von von hörern in syrien selbst auch
obwohl wir uns dann natürlich fragen wer
das genau ist wer sich da wäre damit
wird das natürlich auch das
und und dass das ist natürlich auch
eines der risiken unseres projekts und
das ist auch im verfahren selbst ein
risiko gewesen dass zeugen die aussagen
möglicherweise mit repression aus
damaskus rechnen müssen deswegen haben
wir da ^ ^ vorsichtig sind die an die
sache herangegangen und haben dann
bestimmte zeugen oder oder syrer die die
die dinge geteilt haben im podcast
anonymisiert teilweise auch der stimme
anonymisiert um auf ihre frage
zurückzukommen die reaktionen waren sehr
vielfältig auch über die sozialen medien
in denen wir aktiv sind auch auf
arabisch haben wir viele positive
rückmeldungen bekommen
ich möchte vielleicht ein beispiel
rausnehmen weil sich das so interessant
fand es war ein junger syrer der glaube
irgendwie wahrscheinlich
mitte 20 oder so der sagte auf auf
twitter ja dieser podcast und hier der
link des der besta podcast zu dem syrien
thema finde ich und zwar nicht nur
inhaltlich und und dadurch dass wir
zugang bekommen können zu diesen
informationen sondern auch weil er eben
gemacht wird und mit gestaltet und
produziert wird von syrern in unserem
alter von unserer generation das da hab
ich da muss ich kurz drüber nachdenken
habe es dann auch besprochen wird mein
syrischen kollegen und das war noch mal
ganz interessante augenöffner für mich
weil dieser diese kommentar sagt
eigentlich dass es für diese jüngere
syrische generation einen eine neue
erfahrung überhaupt ist informationen
also aus medien bekommen zu können die
nicht nur von ihresgleichen gemacht
werden sondern eben auch also sozusagen
eine eine direkte linie zwischen hin
zwischen den generationen im gegensatz
zu der bisherigen erfahrung wo einfach
komplette überwachung der medien und
komplette überwachung der der ganzen
informationsflusses durch den staat
stattgefunden hatten also in dem sinne
wir haben wir da glaube ich ganz gut und
sagen unseren kleinen unseren kleinen
beitrag leisten können
nun wird es ja nicht der letzte prozess
gewesen sein was sind denn du die
lessons learned die erkenntnisse aus
diesem verfahren vielleicht auch an
welche an welche grenzen er auch
gestoßen ist was würden sie sagen was
muss noch besser werden
ja wir haben eben schon kurz darüber
geredet es ist jetzt auch sehr aktuell
ich glaube dass mit einem kollegen
gesprochen heute noch auf englisch
gesagt of the dead 2 ist bevor die trial
übermorgen beginnt ein strafverfahren in
frankfurt am oberlandesgericht gegen den
angeklagten allem der ein ehemaliger
militär arzt aus syrien ist und dem
vorgeworfen wird in seiner rolle da im
militärkrankenhaus gefoltert zu haben
relativ schreckliche tat vorwürfe kann
man online nachlesen und da ist
natürlich die große hoffnung dass jetzt
auch dinge die im koblenzer prozess
vielleicht noch nicht so gut gelaufen
sind
da besser laufen werden es ist
allerdings in der community in der wir
uns so ein bisschen bewegen von dem was
wir hören
zu vermuten dass da sich nicht viel
getan hat und das ist natürlich
irgendwie enttäuschen dass wir haben
eben schon über den zugang auch über die
sprache geredet die die zukunft
übersetzungen diese genau diese systeme
wurde auch beim olg in frankfurt schon
angetragen und scheint erst mal
abgeschmettert worden zu sein die
tonaufnahmen dass das es wird auch
wieder eine diskussion werden dann
müssen wir gucken wie sich das
entwickelt die ja die abschriften wird
es nach wie vor nicht geben das ist im
endeffekt natürlich auch einfach weil
das deutsche
strafprozessrecht eventuell nicht mehr
hergibt da müsste schon eine
gesetzesänderung
müssten gesetzesänderungen her und und
das ist vielleicht etwas zu kurzfristig
gewesen jetzt für diesen fall sollte
aber auf jeden fall auch politisch im
politischen sinne und von den gesetzes
machern aufgegriffen dass damit das
besser wird ein anderer punkt sind noch
die zeugen das war ein heikles thema in
koblenz das wird jetzt auch wieder ein
heikles thema werden in frankfurt weil
eben das regime nach wie vor fest im
sattel sitzt in damaskus sind die
sicherheitsbedenken von vielen zeugen
einfach absolut real und muss da sehr
sehr akribisch und gut
sensibel von den behörden und vom
gericht damit umgegangen werden das war
nicht immer der fall in koblenz obwohl
ich sagen kann von dem was ich
mitbekommen habe dass das gericht hat
schon versucht hat das beste daraus zu
machen es ist auch einfach ein
hochkomplexes thema und deswegen wird es
auch in frankfurt in anderen prozessen
schwierig bleiben ja also ein
meilenstein war es auf jeden fall das
urteil des olg koblenz
gegen anna aber es ist in der tat noch
viel zu tun herr streif herzlichen dank
dass sie uns der den sehr intensiven
einblick gegeben haben in das verfahren
und auch in ihrer arbeit besten dank
dann ging er
ja und nach dem prozess nach dem urteil
ist vor dem prozess an diesem mittwoch
herrscht reifert es ihm schon gesagt hat
der pro zweite prozess dieses kalibers
begonnen nämlich vor dem
oberlandesgericht frankfurt
so jetzt geht es aber weiter mit den
gewerbemieten und dem lockdown der uns
sehr nun schon seit anderthalb jahren
fast zwei jahren auch vor gericht
beschäftigt pia was war da los ja da hat
der bundesgerichtshof direkt nach den
weihnachtsferien würde ich sagen mal so
eine der meist erwarteten entscheidung
des jahres raus gehauen das betraf ja so
ziemlich alle einzelhandels gastronomie
wir erinnern uns in lockdown wurde alles
auf staatliche anordnung komplett
geschlossen ich weiß noch wie ich damals
mit einer freundin diskutiert habe die
zwei restaurants haben und die total
empört war dass sie weiter miete zahlen
sollte und wenn sie doch keine einnahmen
mehr erzielen konnte und meinte dann
jetzt denkt doch mal mit mir her
juristisch das ist doch ein mangel der
mietsache und meinen einwand damals dass
das doch aber mit der mietsache
eigentlich gar nichts zu tun hat und
dass doch der vermieter oder die
vermieterin dafür doch genauso wenig
kann wie sie und die ja auch mit ihren
umsätzen irgendwie kalkulieren hat sie
damals irgendwie nicht so richtig
überzeugt vielleicht lag es an der
persönlichen betroffenheit jedenfalls
war das nicht natürlich nicht nur ein
problem meiner freundin sondern landauf
landab gab es dann irgendwie themen und
ganz viele mieterinnen und mieter und
vermieter konnten sich natürlich auch
nicht gütlich einigen das heißt das ging
dann durch die instanzen beiden gericht
und jetzt interessanter weise hat der
bgh euch beiden recht gegeben
ein bisschen schon
das war auch so ich glaube tatsächlich
dass sich alle erhofft hatten das gäbe
jetzt vom bgh eine entscheidung wo man
vielleicht sagen kann so das problem ist
eigentlich überall gleich wir machen das
jetzt irgendwie mal pauschal so und dann
erledigen sich eine ganze menge
verfahren bei den gerichten und auch
halt ne ganze menge streitigkeiten
zwischen mieterinnen und mietern und
ihren vermieten aber nicht so der bgh
einige oberlandesgerichte hatten nämlich
gesagt wir können das ein das risiko
eines lockdown es kommt halt einfach
wieder aus der sphäre des mieters noch
der vermieterin
und deswegen sagen wir einfach wie gehen
pauschal runter auf die hälfte der miete
also mieten müssen einfach die hälfte
der miete zahlen so klingt total
pragmatische genau richtig ich glaube
das hat man auch wirklich viele erwartet
und einmal zumindest erhofft aber der
bgh es leider völlig anders gemacht und
hat gesagt also erstens es ist zwar
denkbar dass man einen anspruch auf
anpassung des mietvertrags hat wenn das
geschäft wegen des staatlich
angeordneten doktorand schließen muss
aber eine pauschale hälftige kürzung der
miete hält der bgh für komplett
unmöglich er sagt wirklich sehr deutlich
schon in seiner pressemitteilung es
bedarf einer konkreten prüfung welche
nachteile der mieter eigentlich jetzt
wirklich erlitten hat und welche
kompensationen ja auch dafür erhalten
hat also nix hier irgendwie machen das
man pauschal hälfte hälfte oder so
sondern prüfung im einzelfall kurz für
die jura 19 draußen der bgh hat
tatsächlich durchgeprüft mangel der
mietsache lob sehr runtergebrochen genau
deshalb was ich damals zu meiner
freundin auch gesagt hat diese gebrauchs
beschränkung der mietsache steht halt
nicht im zusammenhang mit der konkreten
beschaffenheit der mietsache also den
zustand oder der lage oder was hat sonst
irgendwie ein mietmangel ausmacht aber
der bgh sagt sehr klar das kann also das
ist eine störung der geschäftsgrundlage
also wir sind in § 313 bürgerliches
gesetzbuch da gab es ja noch so eine
lustige neue corona sonder vorschrift
die wurde eingefügt ich glaube ende 2020
im artikel 240 § 7 einführungsgesetz zum
bürgerlichen gesetzbuch und die vermutet
bei lockdown schließungen eine störung
der geschäftsgrundlage aber eigentlich
benutzt der bgh die gar nicht sondern
sagte nur ja da steht es auch drin ist
aber sowieso unfall von 313 und zwar
kannte ich jetzt persönlich nicht
vielleicht wissen dass alle da draußen
außer mir betroffen ist die so genannte
große geschäftsgrundlage also quasi die
erwartungen der vertragsparteien dass
sich die grundlegenden verhältnisse
nicht ändern dass die eigene soziale
existenz nicht erschüttert wird das ist
also keine kriege gibt oder
umweltkatastrophen oder was auch immer
so richtig umwälzende politische oder
wirtschaftliche veränderungen der
rahmenbedingungen
aber jetzt kommt diese gestörte
geschäftsgrundlage reicht eben nicht aus
sagt der bio ja denn § 313 verlangt ja
auch noch das der mieterin oder dem
mieter ein festhalten an dem
unveränderten vertrag und zumutbar wäre
und deswegen hatte die ganze kiste
zurück war wiesen an das
berufungsgericht
und das berufungsgericht muss jetzt sehr
detailliert prüfen welche nachteile der
mieter erlitten hat und welche vorteile
er erlangt hat also die müssen jetzt
ganz konkret auf den tisch legen was
sind die konkreten wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen wie viel umsatz habe ich
verloren in der zeit der schließung
dabei kommt es nicht darauf an wie viel
umsatz hat der konzern verloren sondern
da geht es immer nur um das konkrete
geschäft also im zweifel die filiale die
dicht gemacht wurde
der mieter muss auch darlegen welche
maßnahmen ergriffen hat oder hätte
ergreifen können um solche verluste zu
verhindern also zum beispiel hätte man
nicht viel mehr online verkaufen müssen
oder so oder so was ist daher denkbar
und die wird helfen die der geflossen
sind gegangen sie haben vorteile die er
bekommen hat muss er hat muss er gegen
rechnen also ich glaube das ist ja jetzt
auch schon recht unterschiedlich wie
viele vorteile die dann tatsächlich
bekommen haben zumal er dann im
nachhinein einiges dann als darlehen
deklariert wurde also so corona
soforthilfen und so sagt der bgh die
müssen natürlich gegengerechnet werden
sofern diese eben nicht nur auf
darlehens basis gewährt wurden also klar
wenn man es zurückzahlen muss dann war
es natürlich ein vorteil den man
erhalten hat und das fand ich auch ganz
spannend der bgh macht einen kleinen
schlenker und sagt möglicherweise ist
auch ein vorteil die man gegen rechnen
muss eine möglicherweise
einstandspflicht igge betriebs
versicherung des mieters oder der
mieterin das könnte man vielleicht als
vorgriff sehen denn in der kommenden
woche verhandelt der bundesgerichtshof
über die betriebsschließung versicherung
und ob die wahl ob und wann die
eintreten müssen wenn eben pandemie
bedingten lockdown kam könnte man
vielleicht schon sagen ist das ein
bisschen ein vorgriff auf das was kommt
ich glaube es ehrlich gesagt nicht weil
wie gesagt das ist nächste woche ersten
verhandlungstermin unter bgh sagt eben
auch die interessen des vermieters
dürfen nicht vergessen werden bei
alledem wie gesagt vermieter kalkulieren
ja auch mit dem geld das da irgendwie
rein kommt
allerdings braucht es keine gefahr für
die wirtschaftliche existenz des mieters
also der mieter muss nicht sagen ich
stehe jetzt hier vor dem kompletten
breakdown und nur dann wird darf ich
irgendwie meine miete kürzen das braucht
man nicht mario pragmatische lösung ist
jetzt nicht ja dann alles wie es ist ich
kann so ein bisschen nachvollziehen weil
die die realität ist ja leider
inzwischen auch wirklich alles andere
als eindeutiger eben durch diese ganzen
wirtschaftshilfen nieder geflossen sind
und die ja durchaus auch kurzarbeiter
wäre an dieser stelle vielleicht auch zu
nennen sind ja auch viele geschäfte
viele insbesondere restaurants oder
hotels sind ja dann auch in die
kurzarbeit gegangen haben da auch
finanzielle unterstützung bekommen also
die gemenge lage und die die opfer
beschreibung ist gar nicht mehr so
leicht zu treffen insofern macht es
diese ganze sache
komplizierter also oder vielleicht sagen
wir mal vorneweg es ist immerhin ja was
den mietern irrt entgegenkommt ist das
nicht pauschal gesagt wurde seit an den
mietvertrag gebunden ihr müsst weiter
zahlen egal was kommt das ist ja auch
nicht so gewesen
sondern ganz im gegenteil hier steht ja
durchaus jetzt bei jedem mietvertrag im
raum dass da es zu neuverhandlungen
kommen kann bzw zu einer neuberechnung
kommen kann aber sie ist eben nicht mehr
so pauschal wie du gesagt hast und die
oberlandesgerichte das mitunter
vorgegeben haben
also es ist ich fand auch ein bisschen
lustig weil jetzt wieso die rezeption
des urteils war die mieterinnen und
mieter alle sagten siehste wir müssen
gar nicht die volle miete bezahlen haben
wir doch immer gesagt und hier
vermietenden sagte seht mal irgendwie
von wegen einfach mal pauschal die
mieter auf die hälfte kürzen so geht's
ja nicht haben wir ja schon immer gesagt
also ein bisschen steht man eigentlich
da wo man irgendwie am anfang auch
gestanden hätte denn ich bin total bei
dir natürlich ist das kein fall von
einer pauschalen reduktion auf 50
prozent nur einfach weil die
sachverhalte so unterschiedlich sind und
weil es den leuten die da betroffen
waren auf beiden seiten so
unterschiedlich gehen kann dass ich es
merkwürdig gefunden hätte wenn der ph
die kappung auf die hälfte irgendwie
mitgegangen ihrer wäre natürlich total
praktisch gewesen aber es wäre glaube
ich einfach nicht richtig gewesen und
übrigens auch formal nicht machbar weil
ich kann halt einfach nicht die zweite
voraussetzung von 313 bgb weg ignoriert
so ist es nun mal übrigens ein kleiner
hinweis auch noch wir hatten jetzt
sowohl in der zeitung als auch auf faz
einspruch ein gastbeitrag von zwei
anwälten also eine anwältin und einen
anwalt der kanzlei field fisher der
erschienen ist und der sich dieses
urteil noch einmal genau angesehen hat
und gesagt hat naja also interessant ist
jetzt da wie die rolle des film des
mieters ist ja denn der vermieter
ehrlich gesagt ist ja fein raus er kann
er jetzt sagen also ich habe meinen
vertrag punkt nur der mieter hat er
jetzt die darlegungslast und die
verpflichtungen sich quasi nackig zu
machen und zu sagen also das habe ich
bekommen das war meine auf der anderen
seite die eu womöglich
existenzbedrohenden maßnahmen die mich
getroffen haben die umsatzeinbrüche und
so weiter und so fort das heißt auf
seiten des mieters ist dann natürlich
wesentlich mehr zu tun ja wesentlich
mehr darzulegen in so ein prozess könnte
schwierig werden und könnte vielleicht
auch dazu führen dass man sich
wesentlich häufiger als bisher dann in
den vergleich retten das war so ein
bisschen die quintessenz ich tue den
artikel gerne auch noch in die show
notes und da noch mal den hinweis darauf
dass ich glaube dann wirklich nur zu
lesen ist mit einem faz einspruch abo
oder mit einem normalen aber jedenfalls
was für ein eleganter übergang ja ist
das
bezahlpflicht ich wenn ich das an dieser
stelle mal sagen darf im gegensatz zu
diesem podcast der woche für woche
kostenlos sendet und deswegen möchte ich
das mal wieder habe ich ja schon lange
nicht mehr mit einer mit einer bitte um
ein abo verbinden ja also wer uns
unterstützen möchte der kann einen abo
abschließen für faz einspruch oder auch
für die normale zeitung und hilft uns
damit auch sehr denn alles was der faz
hilft hilft uns auch so also sind wir
denn am ende jetzt was dieses urteil
angeht vom bgh wir sind damit total
durch empire zentimetern und mieter in
der pflicht und müssen sich überlegen
machen mache ich mich nackig um das
alles irgendwie darzulegen um da die
monatsmiete von vielleicht maximal
monaten zu sparen also da muss man jetzt
einfach sich noch mal an einen tisch
setzen
gut und dann kommen wir jetzt zu einem
anderen durchaus heiklen thema nämlich
der paragraf
219 die werbung für den abbruch von
schwangerschaften
und das ist jetzt ein bisschen das erste
vorhaben vom neuen justizminister marco
buschmann der irgendwie gefühlt gerade
mal im amt ist und schon den ersten
gesetzentwurf raushaut und das
werbeverbot für schwangerschafts
abbrüche streichen will tenor immer
vielleicht zu aller erst mal was steht
denn da eigentlich genau drin im 92 ja
das ist eine regelung die es schon
wirklich ziemlich alt geht übrigens auf
eine vorschrift zurück die es schon seit
1933 in kraft ist und die soll
eigentlich dem schutz des ungeborenen
lebens diene also darum geht es
natürlich immer diese abwägung zwischen
dem schutz des ungeborenen lebens und
deren rechte der mutter der frau der
sich selbst über ihre schwangerschaft
und über ihren körper zu befinden so und
da gibt es eben auch versucht man
sozusagen alles um schwangerschafts
abbrüche so schwer wie möglich zu machen
ja so selten wie möglich überhaupt
vorkommen zu lassen und deswegen hat man
sich eben auch entschieden da möglichst
rigide zu sein was mit der werbung was
die werbung angeht ja und sie richtet
sich konkret an ärztinnen und ärzte die
schwangerschafts abbrüche vorziehen und
die müssen eben mit strafrechtlicher
verfolgung rechnen wenn sie sachliche
informationen über ablauf und methode
des schwangerschaftsabbruchs
bereitstellen oder eben in versammlungen
so heißt es so schön im § 209 10 a oder
durch verbreiten eines inhalts darüber
berichten ja also vielleicht kann man
das dann an der stelle direkt mal sagen
das ist tatsächlich so dass 219 an
seiner überschrift sagt werbung
aber eben auch schon verbietet auch nur
sachlich darüber zu informieren mit
welchen methoden ärztinnen und ärzte
einen schwangerschaftsabbruch quasi
anbieten und durchführen das also unter
werbung stellt man sich ja immer
irgendwie so keine ahnung wie die bunte
farben vor und so nah sondern es geht
jetzt aber wirklich hier noch einen
schritt weiter und der die vorschrift
verbietet sachliche informationen und
bis 2019 durfte man noch nicht mal auf
seiner webseite als ärztin angeben dass
man überhaupt schwangerschaftsabbrüche
durchführen denn da wurde der absatz
hier damals eingefügt genau und das ist
übrigens eine enorm für alle die die das
nicht so konkret verfolgt haben aber die
diese normen auch tatsächlich schon was
sagt wenn man das ja doch in der
diskussion ist die relativ altes ich
kann auch noch mal dazu sagen das ist
mit dem fall oder mit dieser ganzen
diskussion haben wir uns zum ersten mal
in folge 45
beschäftigt damals eben auch noch mit
meinem kollegen constantin von linden
und da haben wir uns schon mal gekümmert
das war 2018 um die diese diskussion
rund um die gießener
frauenärztin frau kennen vielleicht du
hast ja tatsächlich mal kennengelernt
vielleicht erzählt summe ein bisschen
worum es damals eigentlich ging also
kennengelernt ist vielleicht etwas zu
viel gesagt ich war damals tatsächlich
vor dem amtsgericht diesen quasi als
prozess berichterstatterin damals war in
meinem job für die little tribune online
vor ort und habe da eben unter anderem
mit ihr gesprochen mit ihrer damaligen
verteidigerin der professor monika
frommel also christina handel ist eine
frauenärztin aus gießen die auf ihrer
webseite damals angegeben hatte dass sie
schwangerschafts abbrüche durchführt und
ich meine damals auch schon wie sie
durchführt und dann wurde die angezeigt
von sogenannten lebensschützern die
nennen sich in teilen silber so man kann
sich das gut überlegen ob man das so
sieht das heißt es sind natürlich primär
männer die es ist sich tatsächlich zur
aufgabe gemacht haben nach ärztinnen und
ärzten im netz zu suchen die ihres
erachtens gegen den paragrafen
2219 a stgb verstoßen so und dann haben
sie im strafanzeigen gestellt in vielen
fällen wurden diese strafanzeigen
eingestellt klar von der
staatsanwaltschaft aber in den fällen wo
natürlich dann irgendwie diese
informationen einfach im internet stand
und womöglich sogar auch noch tritt
stand irgendwie wie diese ärzte so einen
abbruch vornehmen
dann mussten die staatsanwaltschaften
weiter ermitteln so eben auch in gießen
und die christina henne die darf man
glaube ich mit fug und recht als
überzeugungstäterin bezeichnen die ist
durch die instanzen gegangen also die
hat
2021 gegen alle ihre verurteilungen in
allen drei instanzen
verfassungsbeschwerde auch noch angelegt
und damals vor dem amtsgericht gießen
das hat für relativ viel wirbel gesorgt
war auch echt viel los ich meine es ist
das amtsgericht in gießen das muss man
sich jetzt irgendwie klar machen da sind
jetzt wahrscheinlich eher selten
irgendwie sprechchöre und
demonstrantinnen vor allem also vor
allem frauen vor dem vor dem gericht das
war aber damals tatsächlich der fall und
das ist halt ganz stark feministisch
belegtes thema im gnade der 219 a und
man muss schon sagen dass ich damals
echt mitleid mit der amtsrichterin hatte
die das entscheiden musste weil
natürlich die verteidigung von christina
handle dann auch sehr vehement
eingefordert hat sich doch mit einer
möglichen verfassungswidrigkeit von 219
mal zu beschäftigen und so und diese
arme amtsrichterin saßen da und die
musste eben einfach nachdem entscheiden
was im gesetz steht und auch ganz klar
im gesetz steht die konnte natürlich da
auch nicht irgendwie sich
verfassungsrechtlich mit der materie
beschäftigen wie das professor monika
frommel konnte und auch gerne und aus
tiefster überzeugung getan hat also das
war schon irgendwie ein etwas absurdes
verfahren was glaube ich auch vom
amtsgericht gießen durchaus irgendwie
ein bisschen seltenheitswert hatte es
hat übrigens auch wirklich großen
unterhaltungswert aber sie hätte doch
vorlegen können oder sie hätte doch
jeder also wenn vorliegen wenn sie die
vorschrift für 219 affe
verfassungswidrig gehalten hätte und da
muss ich sagen das finde ich auch so ein
bisschen spannend dass dabei auch damals
die diskussion und diese diskussion ist
jetzt völlig abgeebbt also jetzt auch im
referentenentwurf den marco buschmann
vorgelegt hat ist von einer möglichen
verfassungswidrigkeit von den 219 nicht
mehr die rede und ich muss auch sagen
ich hätte meine zweifel daran ob man
sagt dass diese vorschriften zwingen
verfassungswidrig ist man kann die
bestimmt aus anderen gründen irgendwie
streichen wollen zweifelhaft finden und
so aber dafür hätte man sie ihn für
verfassungswidrig halten müssen und ich
glaube das war dann vielleicht auch
damals einfach der erkennenden
amtsrichterin echt ein bisschen too much
alles die haben sich dann gedacht na ja
gut da kann sich die nächste instanz mit
rumschlagen haben ja dann auch lg und
olg getan beide haben christina panel
wieder verurteilt und das eben obwohl
dann 2019 also danach der absatz 4
eingefügt
genau dazu kommen wir jetzt mal den
offensichtlich war ja da schon die
diskussionen im vollen gange und es
wurde ersichtlich dass da etwas getan
werden muss weil um das vielleicht jetzt
auch mal deutlich zu sagen denn diese
lebens wie hast du sie genannt die
lebensschützer leer ist schütter kranken
natürlich da auch eine politische agenda
gefahren und haben eben auch versucht so
wie es wahrscheinlich bei umgekehrt bei
frau hänel auch der fall warne man
versucht der das jeweils eben für die
eigenen zwecke zu instrumentalisieren
und hier wurde einfach ziemlich deutlich
auch das strafrecht dazu genutzt um
ärzte auch davon abzubringen überhaupt
darüber zu informieren und die frauen
die gelegenheit zu geben überhaupt
abzutreiben dass das war die
stoßrichtung da hat auch die große
koalition also von union und spd erkannt
da müssen wir womöglich noch mal ran an
den 219 a und haben ein absatz 4
eingefügt der jetzt schon mehr
information ermöglichte den ärztinnen
und ärzte die durften nämlich einerseits
auf schwangerschaft auf die möglichkeit
von schwangerschaftsabbrüchen
hinweisen auch dass sie die durchführen
aber für weitere informationen
insbesondere was für möglichkeiten es da
gibt was für ob chirurgische oder
medikamentös das alles durften sie
selber nicht beschreiben sondern dazu
mussten sie ihm verlinken auf entweder
behörden aus aus dem bund oder im land
gibt ja zum beispiel auch die
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung oder es gibt auch
verschiedene
beratungsstellen die natürlich vielfach
informationen darüber im netz haben aber
die ärztinnen und ärzte dürften das eben
nicht selber auf ihrer internetseite
detailliert auf schreiben sondern
durften nur darauf verweisen und diese
behörden wiederum haben dann listen
gehabt wo
sie auch die schwanger schwangeren
hinter weisen konnten an welcher ärzte
sie sich wenden könnten das war also die
reform die im jahr
2009 10 ihr vollzogen wurde und die aber
nicht dazu führte so ist jedenfalls das
argument von
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann
dass da jetzt rechtssicherheit für die
ärztinnen und ärzte eingekehrt wäre denn
er sagt relativ deutlich na ja es ist
schon so ein bisschen grotesk dass wir
einerseits hier die systematik haben
also übrigens an zwei stellen groteskes
erste ist dass er sagt naja
schwangerschafts abbrüche sind ja in
bestimmten konstellationen straff rainer
wir haben die konstellation dass
vielleicht noch mal für alle erklärt
dass wir in 218 ein grundsätzliches
verbot haben von
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen und auch eine
strafe die da verhängt wird und in
paragraph 218 a werden ausnahmen
definiert unter welchen umständen solche
schwangerschafts abbrüche
straffrei bleiben können ja das heißt
wir haben hier situationen in das sind
viele viele situationen die meisten
eigentlich dass die berühmte der
fristenlösung auch eine dass man in den
ersten zwölf wochen eben nach einem
beratungsgespräch und wenn das durch ein
arzt durchgeführt wird das in der regel
straffrei bleibt später dann natürlich
auch wenn die das leben der mutter in
gefahr ist so das heißt wir haben hier
situation wo der schwangerschaftsabbruch
selber straflos ist aber die werbung
oder auch nur das informieren für die
ärztinnen und ärzte
bestraft wird das ist ja schon wirklich
ein bisschen bizarr und auf der anderen
seite sagte er das zweite was er ihnen
sehr gestört haben dass ärztinnen und
ärzte die das machen die erfahrung damit
gesammelt haben die einzigen sein sollen
die nicht umfassend darüber informieren
dürfen also im netz kann sich quasi
jeder dazu äußern über schwangerschafts
abbrüche egal ob er davon weiß oder
nicht weiß aber ausgerechnet die die das
durchführen und auch aus der praxis
kennen dürfen eigentlich wirklich nur
sehr eingeschränkt auf ihrer
internetseite informieren und das fand
der skurril muss man ja auch sagen
zurecht na ja also ich finde das lässt
sich zumindest absolut hören was hat er
jetzt gemacht wirklich ziemlich rigoros
gesagt nach monat amtszeit liegt der
referentenentwurf vor und gesagt also
219 a wird komplett abgeschafft so und
den rest sei da kommt jetzt auch kein
ersatz oder so sondern er sagt eben
diese marktschreierische werbung die
jetzt vielleicht der eine oder die
andere befürchtet die wird schon jetzt
verhindert durch das standesrecht der
ärztinnen und ärzte ja also konkret
nennt er § 27 absatz 3 der ob
berufsordnungen der landesärztekammern
ja und da steht auch explizit den berufs
widrige werbung ist untersagt und das
ist insbesondere dann der fall wenn es
eine anpreisen de irreführende oder
vergleichende werbung gibt hältst du das
für vergleichbar mit dem 29 also ich
muss offen gestehen ich habe ich finde
das erstmal schlüssig also es ist
natürlich nicht vergleichbar so zu sagen
weil das kann es ja auch gar nicht sein
denn der 27 absatz 3 sei ja nicht
informationen generell verbieten sondern
eben nur diese marktschreierische
werbung also und das vielleicht mal
deutlich zu sagen wo da die
argumentation und die kritik herkommt
wir haben zum beispiel in interview in
der faz gehabt am montag war es lege ich
auch gern mal in die show notes das war
mit elisabeth winkelmeier becker von der
cdu dies die vorsitzende des
rechtsausschusses im bundestag die
fürchtet eben das künftig für
schwangerschafts abbrüche in den
sozialen medien zum beispiel geworben
wird und zwar so wie schönheits für
schönheitsoperationen jetzt auch ja das
war so ihr bedenken ich muss offen
gestehen ich finde der 27 absatz 3 der
berufsordnung würde das schon abdecken
ich glaube nicht dass wir hier
tatsächlich auch ethisch kann ich mir
echt gesagt überhaupt nicht vorstellen
dass es ärztin und ärzte gibt die diesen
weg gehen und dass die tatsächlich mehr
und anders dafür werben als nur mit
nüchternen beschreibung ist kann ich
mich gesagt gar nicht vorstellen
deswegen wäre mein petitum oder könnte
ich mir gut vorstellen dass es in der
tat ausreicht hast du da bedenken
also ich es gibt ja auch manchmal so ein
bisschen dieses argument naja das ist
halt nur berufsrecht und die sind wie
dann steht man vor der ärztekammer und
nicht vor dem start und so ich sehe das
eigentlich auch eher weniger als risiko
zumal ist ja auch tatsächlich in den
vergangenen jahren so ist dass man
tatsächlich eher weniger ärztinnen und
ärzte gefunden hat die überhaupt
schwangerschafts abbrüche vornehmen
wollen und zwar auch mit dem argument
naja wir setzen uns doch hier nicht
diesen sogenannten lebensschützern aus
die uns angreifen sozusagen also ich
glaube eigentlich nicht dass das jetzt
die sorge sein muss dass ärzte da
wahnsinnig vorpreschen und irgendwie mit
den schritten mit grellen farben für
schwangerschafts abbrüche werben zumal
ja ist auch sozusagen dann innerhalb der
ärzteschaft probleme geben könnte das
ist ja auch eine wettbewerbsrechtliche
thema also das heißt wenn ein arzt
feststellt dass eine ärztin nebenan da
irgendwie immer ich sage mal
marktschreierischen art dafür wirbt dass
sie abtreibungen vornimmt dann wird auch
dieser arzt sich beschweren also ich
glaube eigentlich auch dass dieses
berufs rechtliche konstrukt bei den
kammern da angesiedelt das ein bisschen
ähnlich wie beim in der anwaltschaft
dass das ganz gut funktioniert und dass
da auch die gegenseitige kontrolle
durchaus ganz gut funktionieren kann
vielleicht sollte man eben noch mal
sagen was vielleicht was auch eben diese
sorge ist die unter anderem elisabeth
winkelmeier becker in dem interview in
der faz geäußert hat das geht ja immer
darum dass sich die öffentliche
wahrnehmung dann verändert also dass
irgendwann dieses gefühl sich einstellt
dass schwangerschaftsabbruch ein
alltäglicher der normalität
entsprechender vorgang sei ja und ich
halte es also ich mir gesagt man weiß
natürlich nicht wie es weitergeht aber
nach dem was ich auch so aus der
ärzteschaft hörer von gynäkologinnen und
gynäkologen höre ist es glaube ich nicht
das was man im moment befürchten muss
weil es eben eher zu wenige ärztinnen
und ärzte die überhaupt abbrüche
vornehmen möchten als zu viele und man
sich teils wahnsinnig sorgen machen
müsste das dann plötzlich werbungs mäßig
durch die decke geht und wenn ich
schwangerschaftsabbruch google dann
irgendwie ich plötzlich der zehn
anzeigen findet die mich ebra sie dazu
einladen jetzt auch mal bitte meine
schwangerschaft abzubrechen halte sie
nicht für dich sehr realistisch und auf
der anderen seite gibt es auch bei
frauen die so was durch leiden und
durchführen lassen wollen ja auch um
schwere gewissenskonflikte ich kann das
natürlich jetzt bei weitem nicht für
alle sagen aber alles was man immer
dafür zuhört ist das natürlich dass er
ein wirklich sehr schwerer prozess ist
eine sehr schwere entscheidung die sich
viele auch wirklich nicht leicht machen
und nicht umsonst hat er der gesetzgeber
hier auf einem informations und
beratungsstelle sich zurückgezogen also
schon auch in den 90er jahren als ist
diesen berühmten abtreibungs kompromiss
sozusagen gab da war ja das zentrale
argument wir wollen dass dem gewissen
der frau überlassen die sich umfassend
beraten muss darüber und die eben eine
ordentliche abwägung durchführen lassen
musste und das sind finde ich so pfeiler
die total sinnvoll sind und die glaube
ich auch sehr in der praxis sich
durchaus bewährt haben also jedenfalls
verweilt auch das
bundesjustizministerium auf die zahl der
schwangerschaftsabbrüche die seit 1996
erheblich zurückgegangen sind von also
man die größenordnung zu nennen von
130.000 werne baut im jahr 1996 auf
knapp 100000 im jahr 2020
aber das ist ja jetzt auch quasi das
argument der der gegenseite in
anführungszeichen denn die sagen ja wenn
ich jetzt in 219 einfach streiche
ersatzlos dann gerät dieses ganze system
dass das bundesverfassungsgericht mit
seinen zwei wirklich berühmten und
bahnbrechenden entscheidungen
schwangerschaftsabbruch 1 und 2 die
zweite war dann im jahr 1993 getroffen
hat dieses austarierte system könnte
dann eben sozusagen verloren gehen und
quasi kippen also zu lasten des schutzes
des ungeborenen lebens da hat damals hat
das bundesverfassungsgericht so dass
unter maß definiert und da sagen jetzt
eben vor allem natürlich die union und
so weiter die sagen jetzt dieses sehr
austarierte system könnte dann nicht
mehr funktionieren
da muss man sieht das naturgemäß anders
sagt das ist eben die 219 ist eben keine
säule dieses ganzen systems sondern kann
eben auch gut entfallen und zwar
ersatzlos entfallen das ist eben seine
argumentation er rechne nicht damit dass
das tatsächlich so ein alltäglicher
eingriff wird wird man abwarten müssen
aber ich glaube auch tatsächlich dass
das wirklich für alle betroffenen frauen
soll so eine grundlegende entscheidung
ist dass man diese sich nicht
notgedrungen sehr einfach macht aber
wird man sehen wie siehst du das denn
juristisch also meinst du wenn man nur
den 219 aaraus krieg dass da quasi
dieses system was dann nach den
bundesverfassungsgerichts entscheidungen
entwickelt wurde das du ja vorhin schon
dargestellt hast also grundsätzlich ist
es zwar rechtswidrig einen abbruch
vorzunehmen aber es wird daneben quasi
bin drei monaten nicht bestraft mit dem
beratungsmodell das verpflichten
vorgeschaltet wird meinst du dass sich
dieses system verändern würde nur durch
die streichung des werbeverbots für
ärztinnen und ärzte also wie gesagt ich
finde das schlüssig was da aus dem
bundesjustizministerium kommen dass sie
eben sagen also auf den 219 a kommt es
hier gar nicht an weil es ja genug
informationen gibt im netz so zu sagen
warum sollen nicht ausgerechnet die die
doch die meisten und die besten
informationen haben nicht auch noch
ihren teil dazu beitragen ich sehe da
ehrlich gesagt kaum eine veränderung ja
also insofern interessant da wird's wenn
das passiert was man sonst noch
im koalitionsvertrag steht da ist ja
sehr grundsätzlich die rede davon dass
man überlegt den schwangerschaftsabbruch
neu zu regeln und dem aus dem strafrecht
rauszunehmen und
anders zu gestalten wie dieses anders
aussehen kann weiß man noch überhaupt
nicht aber diese möglichkeit gibt es ja
grundsätzlich die hat auch wohl das
bundesverfassungsgericht
nicht in frage gestellt das ist jetzt
aber im moment die situation in der wir
haben dass es im strafrecht geregelt ist
muss aber nicht auf eine zeit zum
bleiben das in der tat wäre ein größerer
eingriff denke ich
hältst du es denn im moment für naja ich
sage jetzt nicht notwendig sagen aber
vielleicht schlauer das dann dass man so
ein aufgeheiztes thema am anfang der
legislaturperiode auf dem tisch packt
also es gibt ja jetzt einmal die
juristische dimension kann man sich
irgendwie fragen würde das vom
bundesverfassungsgericht im jahr
vermutlich schon aber wie beurteilst du
denn die gesellschaftliche diskussion
denn gerade bei diesen themen ich sag
mal am anfang und ende des lebens
hat ja haben wir die allermeisten
menschen eine sehr klare meinung und
jetzt gerade im moment ist das thema
diskussionskultur ja vielleicht nicht so
hoch gehängt in deutschland oder was
meinst du ja aber davon ehrlich gesagt
kann man sich natürlich als
bundesregierung gar nicht leiten lassen
denn sonst könnte es zu die
regierungsarbeit einstellen ob es jetzt
klimaschutz ist oder auch kurve 19 dann
kommen wir auch gleich noch mal dazu
also das ist dann wirklich ein
unsicheres terrain ich würde sagen was
interessant daran ist dass der
justizminister buschmann schon sehr
deutlich gemacht hat dass er das sein
erstes
projekt es ist ehrlich gesagt natürlich
auch ein relativ einfaches den einfach
ersatzlos zu streichen
das da gehört jetzt auch nicht viel dazu
das zu tun deswegen hat das auch
vorangestellt aber das verbindet sich ja
viel mehr wir haben es auch schon früher
im podcast besprochen dass jetzt
offensichtlich die ampel koalition
angetreten es das familienbild oder auch
gesellschaftlich so einiges zu ändern
und die gesellschaft moderner zu
gestalten ja auch durch die
verantwortungspartner schafften dies da
geben soll durch verschiedene lockerung
die ist überhaupt im
gesellschaftlichen umfeld geben soll da
ist das sozusagen ein erster baustein
und da natürlich dann das einfachste
vorhaben und dann kann ich total
nachvollziehen dass man das vom tisch
haben möchte und wie gesagt ich sehe
auch die große tatsächliche veränderung
nicht wirklich also schwieriger wird es
wirklich und die diskussion werden
heißer wenn man den 218 stgb tatsächlich
anfasst also die strafbarkeit des
schwangerschaftsabbruches das wird noch
mal eine größere frau aber die wird auch
noch dauern und da werden wir dann da
müssen wir uns vertragen das ist dann
überhaupt so weit ist genau wenn die
überhaupt kommt weil es kam mir gerade
eben nicht so einen koalitionsvertrag
rein das kommt jetzt alles aus dem
strafgesetzbuch raus sondern da wird
jetzt erst mal nur eine kommission
eingesetzt die das prüfen soll ja gut
aber dann wäre doch zu diesem punkt
alles gesagt
[Musik]
ja und dann sind wir jetzt auch schon
bei unseren nachträgen ist es so die
diana das ist so aber die sind in dieser
woche finde ich relativ spektakulär vor
allem zum hashtag gelesenen status der
ja gestern bei twitter total
durchgestartet ist denn der genesenen
status wurde verändert und irgendwie hat
es keiner gemerkt ja und zwar schon
vergangenen freitag und ist jetzt seit
anfang der woche tatsächlich auch in den
medien angekommen wird da immer stärker
diskutiert wie ihr erklären mal ganz
nüchtern zunächst mal worum es
eigentlich geht es geht um einerseits
übrigens den genesenen status und den
impfstatus bei beiden haben sich
konkrete änderungen ergeben sowohl
praktisch als auch eine gesetzes
systematik vielleicht fangen wir mit dem
einfachsten mal an also alle genesenen
die die kogit 19 erkrankung überstanden
haben können sich jetzt auf diesen
status eben nur noch 90 tage also drei
monate lang berufen bisher waren es
volle sechs monaten das war ja auch das
was wir immer wieder gesagt haben also
das relevant zum beispiel für die 2g für
die 3g regelungen wie immer nicht nur
geimpfte sondern auch genesene besondere
vorteile haben spielte dieser genießen
status eine rolle so und da das ganze
ist eben geregelt in der kurve 19
schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmeverordnung die
du uns ja dankenswerterweise liebe pia
schon in folge 192 näher gebracht hast
als es ist moment wirklich eine meiner
lieblings eines meiner lieblings
regelungs instrumenten wie kein mensch
kennt obwohl es wirklich unser leben
bestimmt ist ganz absurd ja und
letztendlich ist vielleicht um das mal
kurz zu erklären das ist eine verordnung
die irgendwie sehr einleuchtet die im
grunde genommen nichts anderes tut als
ausnahmen festzulegen von den corona
maßnahmen wie sie ihn in paragraph 28
folgende
infektionsschutzgesetz schon festgelegt
sind die dann in den landesverordnung
weiter ausgeführt werden und wie gesagt
da gibt es ja immer die möglichkeiten
für geimpfte und genesene und mitunter
auch für getestete
ausnahmen von ausnahmen zu profitieren
und das ist in dieser verordnung
geregelt so und was ist nun passiert sie
wurde extrem
flexibilisiert so möchte ich mal sagen
ja also verständlich formuliert es stand
sehr konkret drin was unter einem
genießen den status zu verstehen ist
nämlich konkret die sechs monate die
sollten eigentlich angepasst werden das
war der grund warum das auch vergangene
woche in den bundesrat ging um das
europäische anzugleichen an
180 tage also offensichtlich auf
europäischer ebene rechnet man eher in
tagen als in monaten und da war
eigentlich auf dem plan das ganze
anzupassen von sechs monate auf 180 das
wäre jetzt keine große änderung gewesen
kann man sich leicht ausrechnen das ist
ziemlich nah dran was aber stattdessen
passiert ist ist eben dass jetzt künftig
keine konkrete zahl mehr in dieser kurve
19 schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmeverordnung
steht also konkret in § 2 sondern dass
das verwiesen wird auf die website des
rk ii und das lka also das
robert-koch-institut also eine
staatliche behörde entscheidet jetzt
darüber wie lange man als genesener geht
so und das sind eben nicht mehr die
sechs monate oder die 180 tage wie
ursprünglich avisiert sondern inzwischen
nur noch drei monate begründet wird das
eben mit der tatsache dass wir jetzt
neue wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
haben im zusammenhang mit der neue
virusvariante omikron und
da eben davon auszugehen ist dass man
sich auch früher wieder anstecken kann
das mit der den schutz durch eine
infektion nicht mehr ganz so lange hält
analog übrigens zu denen impfung dass
man deswegen davon ausgeht dass der
schutz schon nach drei monaten
verschwindet und deswegen hat man jetzt
die drei monate eingesetzt so kam die
verkürzung zustande kann also um es noch
mal klar zu machen die drei monate hat
das rk ii eingesetzt darüber wurde nicht
irgendwo entschieden auf politischer
ebene sondern am freitag hat der hat der
bundesrat auch noch bekannt gegeben es
gibt eine verkürzung von von sechs
monaten auf 180 tage und am samstag hat
das robert-koch-institut
sozusagen auf auf war ich weiß nicht ob
auf eigene faust aber jedenfalls das
robert-koch-institut hat auf seiner
webseite veröffentlicht es gibt jetzt
eine verkürzung nicht mehr von 180 tagen
sondern nur noch von 19 also nur noch
drei monate was in der praxis natürlich
ein riesen unterschied macht na also das
muss man ja vielleicht nicht besonders
erklären denn alle die sich vor ich
würde sagen oktober an herbert also die
im sommer krank geworden sind und jetzt
gehofft haben vielleicht noch zusagen
von ihrem genesenen status zu
profitieren können dies nun nicht mehr
das wird schon ordentlich viele leute
betreffen also man weiß noch nicht wie
viele arbeiten paar millionen während
schon sein kann man sich vorstellen was
halt schon blöd wenn man jetzt in urlaub
fahren wollte und dann erfährt man halt
montags aus der presse dass da irgendwie
die die regelungen sich geändert haben
unerfreulich zur vollständigkeit darf
ich noch erwähnen dass das gleiche
prinzip gilt nun und da wird auch
heikel und hochinteressant für den
impfstatus weil da gab es eben auch die
regelung auch in dieser kommune
ausnahmen verordnung mit 19
schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmen verordnung war
eben auch festgelegt ab wann man quasi
als vollständig geimpft gilt das hatten
wir auch schon lange durchexerziert also
nach zwei impfungen normalerweise mit
den helmen art impfstoffen bei johnson &
johnson war reichte nur einer und das
hatten wir hier auch in der tat schon
öfter besprochen im podcast ne dass wir
ja schon gemutmaßt haben dass diese 2g
plus regelung darauf zielt diesen im
status ein bisschen zu modifizieren und
auch die bevölkerung
vorsichtig darauf vorzubereiten dass es
demnächst wahrscheinlich eine änderung
geben wird dass man nämlich eine dritte
impfung braucht eine
auffrischungsimpfung um als vollständig
genesen zu gelten so und das interesse
länder geld richtig entschuldigung
vollständig geimpft nicht vollständig
genesen ist noch mal eine schöne
unterkategorie die vielleicht auch
irgendwann mal fand aber gab es denn
jetzt beim paul-ehrlich-institut auf das
ja beim thema impfungen verwiesen wird
auch schon änderungen seit der änderung
der maßnahmen maßnahmen verordnung genau
also um das noch mal deutlich zu sagen
also das war bisher eben in dieser
verordnung geregelt jetzt wird nicht aus
rk ii verwiesen sondern
konsequenterweise aus paul ehrlich
institut das heißt die klären jetzt wer
vollständig geimpft ist und da ist
deutlich zu lesen wer das betrifft jetzt
alle die mit johnson & johnson geimpft
wurden geld ist ja bisher dass eine
impfung reicht und nun liegt das papier
also dass paul wie es immer so schön
genannt wird also das
paul-ehrlich-institut hat eben jetzt
festgelegt dass es zwei impfungen sind
so es gibt auch keine änderung bezüglich
der m rna impfstoffe also da steht jetzt
überall in dieser reihe eine 2 dh zwei
impfungen sind notwendig um vollständig
geimpft zu sein
das wird das schön aufgelistet nach den
einzelnen impfstoffen das steht überall
noch ne 2 aber es wäre ja denkbar dass
sich daraus bald etwas anderes ergibt
und da demnächst eine 3 steht und zwar
wenn immer das paul ehrlich institut das
für nötig hält und da möchte ich
übrigens mal sagen da habe ich heute mal
aus reinem interesse beim
paul-ehrlich-institut angerufen um zu
fragen wann ist denn jetzt nun soweit
ist also wann die entscheiden dass er im
status sich ändert so und dann bekommt
man erst mal eine sehr verzweifelt
ansage von den presse damen die also auf
wo man nicht aufs band sprechen kann
sondern wo einfach drin steht bitte
schreiben sie uns eine e-mail wegen
überlastung sind wir quasi ist die
pressestelle beschlossen ja und wenn man
dann eine sehr konkrete frage hin
schickt nämlich also wann ist damit so
es ist schon im gespräch das zu ändern
also von zwei impfungen auf 3 und wenn
ja wenn es damit zu rechnen dann bekommt
man eine automatische
antwort vom paul ehrlich institut die
einen wirklich allen lang die also
interessante dinge beschreibt aber
natürlich in keiner weise auf die
konkrete frage ein gegner und hier ist
einfach wie retten sich dann auch darin
ja wichtiger hinweis stand siebzehnter
erster
2022 also das ist jetzt leider auch
schon vorgestern gewesen und fängt
gleich an interviews gibt ausschließlich
der präsident des paul-ehrlich-instituts
und dann wir bitten um verständnis dass
die wenigen zeitfenster die dafür zur
verfügung stehen und so weiter und so
fort wir prüfen jede anfrage und ihm so
steigt täglich die zahl der teils
mehrteiligen anfragen klammer auch so
auch von mir glaubt wo ja wo man einfach
so die verzweiflung herauslesen kann das
tut mir wirklich auch von herzen leid
aber man wird sehen dass dieses dieses
system an seine grenzen stößt das ist
mal eine sehr vorsichtige prognose bin
gespannt wie es weitergeht aber so ist
im moment tatsächlich
die sachlage
ja ich muss sagen ich bin da ein wenig
sprachlos also die wunderbare
professorin andrea kießling hat das bald
bei twitter mal wieder so schön sachlich
wie es ihre art ist zusammengefasst hat
und und hat geschrieben es ist
widersprüchlich dass bundestag und
bundesrat erst ihre einbeziehung
forderten dann aber später einer
verordnung zustimmen die solche
dynamischen verweise enthält ich finde
das ist noch irgendwie so wie soll man
sagen milde ausgedrückt weil ich finde
dass jetzt mal völlig unabhängig von
jeder juristischen bewertung zumindest
kommunikativ äußerst fragwürdig genau
wie du sagst corinne hat dass es ist
nicht die aufgabe des rk ii oder auch
das
den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
deutschland zu erklären warum jetzt
plötzlich die quarantäne kürzer ist
warum man plötzlich nur noch drei monate
irgendwie als genesen gilt oder warum
der impfstatus von johnson johnson
geimpften sich plötzlich verändert hat
sondern das ist aufgabe der politik dass
erstens zu entscheiden und zweitens zu
kommunizieren und ich bin total bei dir
spätestens in der kommunikation der
kommunikationsebene wird das brutal
schaltern wenn wir scheitern wenn man
das dem rk ii und dem zu schicken ich
kann mir auch nicht vorstellen dass sie
damit glücklich sind also um das
vielleicht auch noch mal deutlich zu
sagen es gibt natürlich jetzt auch schon
juristen anzweifeln dass das so seine
richtigkeit hat zum einen wird die norm
klarheit da in frage gestellt normen
vorschriften sollen in sich schlüssig
sein so ausdehnen soll klar hervorgehen
woran man sich zu halten hat da kann man
noch argumentieren naja verweise sind
jetzt nicht mich ungewöhnlich auf der
anderen seite muss man sagen dass es
doch hier und da kommt jetzt die
wesentlichkeit theorie ins spiel doch um
ziemlich wichtige dinge handelt die
tatsächlich
irgendein
legitimiertes organ noch vielleicht
klären gesagt normalerweise
normalerweise fragt man sich ja bei der
wesentlichkeit theorie also die besagt
dass eben wesentliche entscheidungen die
wesentliche konsequenzen haben der
gesetzgeber selbst treffen muss da macht
man sich normalerweise gedanken darüber
dass diese dass diese entscheidung nicht
auf die exekutive verschoben werden
dürfen und nicht auf die wissenschaft
hier ist es sozusagen wesentlichkeit
theorien wir haben es ja hier schon mit
verordnung zu tun also das heißt es ist
ja schon delegiert vom gesetzgeber vom
eigentlichen parlament hin zur regierung
zudem zu der bundesregierung und den
jeweiligen landesregierung und die
delegieren das nochmal also das ist
schon also sehr ungewöhnlich ich bin ja
und ich finde das rad wirklich sehr
erstaunlich muss ich sagen dass man der
wissenschaft diese verantwortung
überträgt weil es ist natürlich total
richtig und nicht dass es jetzt
irgendwann den falschen hals krieg dass
man die wissenschaft befragt zu den
grundlagen von entscheidungen zu den
fakten die die angeben können und zu den
annahmen weil manchmal ist es ja einfach
nicht mehr als das aber die entscheidung
selbst auf die wissenschaft zu
übertragen praktisch ohne kontrolle und
in dem dann einfach wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler auf der webseite
etwas neues veröffentlichen was halt
auswirkungen hat unser massive
auswirkungen auf alle bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesem land finde ich echt
hanebüchen tut mir leid also ich bin
etwas fassungslos ja also ich bin auch
gespannt wie weit so was dann noch trägt
er und ob es nicht nur eine rolle
rückwärts gibt ich würde sagen wir
belassen es erstmal dabei wir haben noch
andere themen die wir an reißen wollen
aber wir gucken definitiv weit darauf so
du hast jetzt noch weitere nachträge zu
vergangener woche ja eigentlich vor
allem einen ich muss eine klarstellung
machen da gab es anfragen von hörerinnen
und hörern ich habe mich da in der
vergangenen woche vielleicht
missverständlich ausgedrückt hat sich
gesagt habe mein halber freundeskreis
müsste sich ja schon ständig ab sondern
weil die korona vanek ja mittlerweile
irgendwie fünf gefühl permanent rot ist
also es ist nicht so natürlich nicht
dass man in quarantäne muss wenn die
korona waren rot leuchtet der offizielle
ratschlag der bundesregierung ist
natürlich schon dass man kontakte meidet
und vor allem dass man einen test macht
am besten nicht nur ein selbsttest
sondern einen professionellen antigen
schnelltest das hält auch
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach für
einen ganz wichtigen baustein zur
pandemie bekämpfung dass man da schon
auf die kommunalwahl app hört aber es
ist nicht so dass man in quarantäne muss
sondern das ist einfach nur so dass der
freundeskreis von pia lorenz ein sehr
sehr brava freundeskreis ist und die
menschen wenn da die waren sehr rot
blinkt dann einfach freiwillig sagen so
leute ich lasse mich jetzt erstmal
testen heute abend sehen wir uns nicht
und dann schauen ob wir und sind drei
tagen also schöne grüße an den sehr
vorbildlichen freundeskreis und piano
gut dass wenn sie jetzt alle gehört
haben die hören uns natürlich alle zu
auch das ist wiederum sehr vorbildlich
so und ich möchte jetzt ich muss auch
noch was korrigieren was mit dann mit
dem schon durch alle ich bin durch mehr
gibt es nicht zu sagen weil ich muss
gestehen ich bei mir ging natürlich auch
ein bisschen was zu hören vergangene
woche ist lässt sich leider auch nicht
ganz vermeiden denn wir arbeiten hier
weitgehend ohne skript so die wichtigen
details schreiben wir uns natürlich auf
aber es ist nicht bei weitem nicht so
dass wir hier die ganze zeit vom blatt
ablesen und dadurch dass man frei
spricht kommt das eine oder andere auch
mal durcheinander so und beim einem
gerechten urteil der woche und da habe
ich in diesem zusammenhang eben darüber
gesprochen dass es hier um eine
diskriminierung geht ich bin den fans
natürlich nicht noch mal aufräumen aber
jedenfalls war das allgemeine
gleichbehandlungsgesetz
gefragt und da ging es natürlich nicht
um eine diskriminierung wegen der
sexuellen orientierung also die frage ob
jemand homosexuell oder heterosexuelle
oder wie auch immer ist sondern es ging
um eine diskriminierung wegen der
sexuellen identität das ist dort auch
ausdrücklich so festgelegt dass ist das
eine und dann habe ich natürlich in
meinem waren auch noch von transsexuelle
personen geredet und gemeint war auch
hier natürlich wieder die intensität ja
also
als mann oder frau oder mann bin ja oder
so weiter ja also das
wollte ich jetzt einfach nur mal
klarstellen ich gebe auch offen zu ich
bewege mich da einfach noch auf
unsicheren tara und freue mich aber
immer wenn mir dann so eine dinge
mitgeteilt werden es war auch diesmal
wieder hören im sehr freundlichen ton
und sehr aufgeklärt und das fand ich
gesagt bringt mich immer weiter und da
sage ich immer gerne mehr davon das
finde ich auch so hoch interessant so
und jetzt habe ich noch ein letztes
nämlich wir wollten doch eine abstimmung
über die reform des jurastudiums mal
auf die sprünge helfen nicht dass man
das müsste dann wird ja schon auf
twitter werbung für gemacht und das
wollten auch wir hier tun es hört sich
nach einer sehr interessanten sachen für
alle die die jura studiert haben oder
auch das ganze studium schon hinter sich
gebracht haben bin mehr oder weniger
verzweiflung da wissen wir nun alle dass
das dringend
reformbedürftig ist dieses studium ja
aber diese reförmchen die ist da in der
vergangenheit gab haben ja nicht dazu
geführt dass er sich tatsächlich viel
geändert hat und deswegen gibt es jetzt
ein verein von jungen juristinnen die
sich diesen discos jetzt mal
strukturiert widmen wollen und jetzt
damit beginnen mal eine abstimmung oder
verschiedene reformansätze zur
abstimmung zu stellen und das wollen wir
natürlich hier auch unterstützen sagen
bitte wenn sie sich angesprochen fühlen
stimmen sie mit ab wir tun den link in
unsere chance und ich kann hier schon
mal sagen wer so fix ist kann sich das
hier auch gleich merken wie
www.ford.de richtig abstimmung und jo
reform wird eu r und dann reform
geschrieben ja aber eben alles noch mal
in die chance dass dazu und jetzt kommen
wir zu unserem geliebten gerechten
urteil
[Musik]
was hast du da hier das gerechte urteil
dieser woche kam gestern und zwar vom
arbeitsgericht köln ist ein gericht dass
es nicht alle tage in die medien schafft
gestern ist das geschehen und man muss
schon sagen es geht um die justiziarin
des erzbistums köln
die gegen ihre kündigung geklagt hat man
könnte jetzt mal zuallererst auf den auf
den gedanken kommen dass das erzbistum
köln doch vielleicht andere sorgen haben
könnte aber auch arbeitsgerichtliche
verfahren muss man führen und ich glaube
das was das arbeitsgericht köln zu
entscheiden hatte war mit sicherheit
nicht das worum es am ende wirklich ging
aber vor gericht ging es um einen
rückenschonenden bürostuhl und das ist
jetzt kein scherz die justiziarin des
erzbistums köln hatte als die pandemie
losging und homeoffice angesagt wurde
ihren rücken schonenden bürostuhl mit
nach hause genommen das muss also im
jahr 2020 gewesen sein im juli 2021 hat
sie ihre fristlose kündigung bekommen
mit der begründung sie habe eben diesen
rückenschonenden stuhl mit heim genommen
hatte das mit dem home office zu tun
oder wie war das
genau also die sind dass das erzbistum
hat gesagt so also nicht gesagt ich
ordne mal an dass alle ins home office
gehen alle arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmer aber sie haben gesagt
bleibt man lieber im home-office wir
haben es aber gleichzeitig offenbar
nicht so richtig auf die kette kriegt
die leute im home office aus zu starten
und dann hat diese justiziarin also die
leiterin der stabsstelle recht hat
gesagt okay ich nehme den stuhl dann
irgendwie mit nach hause so und das war
dann jetzt zumindest offiziell der grund
für ihre kündigung außerordentliche
kündigung im juli 20 21 ich habe leider
keine background info sowohl das
verfahren in köln stattgefunden hat muss
ich sagen
im sommer 2021 ist nämlich die
justiziarin auch noch für dauerhaft
dienstunfähig erklärt wurden und in den
ruhestand versetzen nun auch dagegen ist
die frau vorgegangen die offensichtlich
schon seit sommer 2020 auch nicht mehr
im büro aufgelaufen ist wie gesagt es
ging aber offiziell um ein bürostuhl und
da hat dann tatsächlich das erzbistum
auch argumentiert der bürostuhl habe
aber einen erheblichen wert gehabt und
außerdem hätte die justiz jahren sich ja
kurz nachdem sie den bürostuhl mit nach
hause genommen hat krankgemeldet
wahrscheinlich war dann das argument
dann braucht man ja auch kein bürostuhl
oder so das hat jetzt die kamera am
arbeitsgericht nicht so überzeugt neben
gesagt das ist natürlich eindeutig eine
pflichtverletzung man kann nicht einfach
büromobiliar mit nach hause nehmen
könnte theoretisch auch eine kündigung
begründen aber nicht unter diesen
besonderen umständen denn das erzbistum
hat die home office immerhin dringend
empfohlen und hat dann die notwendige
ausstattung nicht zur verfügung gestellt
und dass es da irgendwie turbulent
zugegangen sei wie der wdr berichtet hat
dass das erzbistum können dass so ein
bisschen als argument angeführt hat hat
das arbeitsgericht jetzt nicht überzeugt
haben sie gesagt das kann auf keinen
fall eine außerordentliche kündigung
begründen sie haben auch die versetzung
der just serien in den ruhestand für
unwirksam erklärt weil man da nicht die
notwendigen medizinischen sachverstand
eingeholt habe das heißt dass erz bist
du musst jetzt jedenfalls mal 55.000
euro gehalt nachzahlen quasi von august
21 21 bis januar dieses jahres
was vergisst man immer in diesem
zusammenhang
genau warum schafft das ganze verfahren
ist überhaupt in die medien natürlich
weil es da eine brisante komponente gibt
denn diese juristin hatte gesagt ich
möchte nicht nur gerne meine 55.000 euro
weil meine kündigung unwirksam war und
und und meinem eine versetzung in den
ruhestand grabmal erst recht sondern sie
hat gesagt ich hätte gerne auch noch
50.000 euro weil sie sich mehr als zehn
jahre lang unter anderem mit der
aufarbeitung von missbrauchsfällen im
bistum köln beschäftigt hatte und mit
dieser psychischen belastung habe das
erzbistum sie alleingelassen da hat das
arbeits jetzt gericht gesagt dafür gibt
es kein schmerzensgeld die aufarbeitung
der missbrauchsfälle seien notwendig
gewesen und die belastungen die damit
für die arbeitnehmenden einhergehen
seien unvermeidbar und da finde ich
jetzt da kommt jetzt noch ein echt
spannendes argument die justiziarin
hätte sich wenn sie eine supervision
wollte oder schulungen oder so um halt
mit diesen psychischen druck umzugehen
der dadurch entsteht dass man sich
permanent mit dieser thematik befassen
muss da hätte sie sich selber drum
kümmern müssen ja das fällt nicht in die
kategorie gerecht dass urteile das
möchte ich vielleicht an dieser stelle
ich weiß nicht wie du siehst aber das
finde ich schon wirklich heikel an
diesem urteilsspruch weil man muss eben
sagen also selbstständig ist das
belasten selbstverständlich übrigens in
bezug auf den eigenen arbeitgeber nein
ja sicherlich auch in einer brenzligen
situation wo es ja wir haben es alle
jetzt in den letzten jahren immer wieder
gesehen wie schwer sich auch die
katholische kirche generell damit getan
hat und das erzbistum köln ganz gerade
das ja so deutlich sagen also das ist
wirklich ihre heike ich finde dass es
selbstverständlich eigentlich dass der
arbeitgeber dafür sorge trägt und gut
dass man das jetzt vielleicht nicht mit
geld ab geld ist vielleicht eine andere
sache aber dann wiederum wie denn sonst
im nachhinein hätten sie mal früher auf
können also der anwalt hat ihr anwalt
hat genauso argumentiert und hat gesagt
sei wo die fürsorgepflicht des
arbeitgebers dafür zu sorgen dass es da
zum beispiel eine supervision gibt oder
so was jetzt ein normaler umgang mehrere
im umgang mit somit so belastenden
dingen und hat dass man relativ schönen
zitat gemacht wünscht nämlich gesagt es
muss doch nicht der arbeitnehmer
einfordern dass er eine trittsichere
leiter bekommen und dann hat das
arbeitsgericht
nun hat das arbeitsgericht gesagt das
finde ich echt ne krasse antwort diese
dame die klägerin eben sei aber keine
malerin oder lack ihre reservierten
sondern die leiterin der stabsabteilung
recht je höher eine position angesiedelt
ist desto mehr eigeninitiative und
selbstverantwortung erwartet man und das
möchte ich unbedingt noch mal sagen wir
halten ja die kategorie gerechtes urteil
immer sehr offen manchmal machen wir
ungerechte urteile diesen teil finde ich
schon wirklich mehr als fragwürdig also
zu sagen dass man jetzt irgendwie weil
man juristin oder jurist ist muss man
sich selber um eine supervision kümmern
was man als malerin nicht gemustert
finde ich schon echt einschränken ansatz
aber wisst ihr bescheid da draußen viele
viele juristinnen und juristen hören und
zu wenn ihr kummer habt geht man lieber
sicher und geht selbst zum arbeitgeber
und sagen die belastung ist hier
ziemlich hoch interessant ich finde
jetzt an dieser stelle auch
interessieren ob das hörerinnen und
hörer anders sehen wer also gerne dann
auch hier mit der entsprechenden
begründung uns eine kleine e mail
schreiben ich sage es nochmal ein sport
podcast faz.de da wäre ja auch mal eine
breitere debatte möglich aber das war
jedenfalls dass gerichte oder der
sendungen das war doch dieser etwas
längliche podcast jetzt wir danken für
die aufmerksamkeit freuen uns übrigens
auch sehr über feedback auf unserer
internetseite und im
store oder und wo immer man bot catcher
wo man uns bewertungen hinterlassen kann
sternchen was auch immer wir natürlich
nur gute ist ja klar auch dir herzlich
unsere bewertung ich danke knapp
draussen eine schöne und gute woche
tauchte auch schöneres woche tür ist
[Musik]